NEW HOUSE MAJORITY WAS TO TAKE
POWER.
NOW THE QUESTION IS, WHAT ARE
MITCH McCONNELL AND SENATE
REPUBLICANS LOOKING TO HELP
DEMOCRATS WITH THEIR MASSIVE
SPENDING SPREE WHEN ALL THEY
SHOULD BE AGREEING TO IS A SHORT
TERM CONTINUING RESOLUTION TO
FUND THE GOVERNMENT SO THE NEW
GOP-CONTROLLED HOUSE WILL HAVE A
SAY AND MY ADVICE IS TO CALL UP
EVERY REPUBLICAN SENATOR AND SAY
NO TO ANY OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL
THAT HELPS SCHUMER AND THE
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS.
WHY ANY REPUBLICAN WOULD GO
ALONG WITH THAT IS MADNESS.
JOINING ME NOW, GOP LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY.
BEFORE I GET TO THE OMNIBUS
PART, HOW DID THAT GO?
>> DIDN'T COME TO ME.
CAME UP TO MY 82-YEAR-OLD
MOTHER.
A LITTLE HARD OF HEARING.
RECENTLY RECOVERING FROM CANCER.
HE SHOOK HER HAND AND SAID
SOMETHING.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
SAID.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO THIS
OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL.
WE'VE HAD SINCE 1954 FIVE
CHANGES IN TERMS OF POWER
CONTROL IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
NOT ONE TIME HAVE WE EVER PASSED
AN OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL IN THE
INTERIM BEFORE THE NEW CONGRESS
WAS SWORN IN.
WHY WOULD A REPUBLICAN SENATOR,
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE FACT
WE JUST HIT $31 TRILLION IN
DEBT.
WHY WOULD THEY GO WITH CHUCK
SCHUMER AND THIS RECKLESS
SPENDING OF THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY AND NOT WAIT
UNTIL YOU CAN BE A CHECK AND A
BALANCE TO ANY MONEY THAT IS
SPENT?
WHY WOULD THAT DO THAT?
WHY WOULD REPUBLICAN SENATORS GO
ALONG WITH THAT?
>> I HOPE THEY WOULD NOT.
FOR ALL OF YOUR VIEWERS, WHAT
DOES AN OMNIBUS MEANS?
THE DOMESTIC SPENDING THAT YOU
BELIEVE IN FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGRICULTURE AND OTHERS WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS, THE TWO PEOPLE
THAT LEAD IN THIS
APPROACHITIONS, SENATOR LEAHY
AND SENATOR SHELBY WILL NO
LONGER BE HERE IN 21 DAYS.
THEY DID NOT RUN FOR
RE-ELECTION.
SO THERE'S NO WAY THAT THE
TAXPAYER OR CONSTITUENTS CAN
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU WAIT 21 MORE
DAYS?
WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
ADDING THE BASELINE, WHERE WOULD
WE START IN THE NEXT YEAR?
THEY WANT TO INCREASE IT BETWEEN
90 AND $130 BILLION.
INSTEAD OF SAVING MONEY, INSTEAD
OF CUTTING BACK IN THIS WORLD OF
INFLATION, WHY WOULDN'T WE -- IF
WE DO NOTHING IN A C.R., WE SAVE
ALMOST $100 BILLION.
THAT'S THE HARD EARNED TAXPAYER
MONEY.
ARE YOU GOING TO GET TIME TO
READ IT?
THEY'RE TRYING TO JAM IT BEFORE
CHRISTMAS.
WHY WOULD YOU MOVE FORWARD WHEN
THERE'S A CHANGE IN POWER IN 21
DAYS WHERE REPUBLICANS WOULD
HAVE A STRONGER HAND?
THAT WE WOULDN'T BE TALKING
ABOUT ADDING MORE MONEY.
WE WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
DECREASING.
HOLDING PEOPLE MORE ACCOUNTABLE,
GETTING RID OF THE WASTE, THE
FRAUD, THE ABUSE.
MAKING SURE THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE HAS THE RESOURCES TO
DEFENDS THEMSELVES.
WHAT COMMITTEE WILL SEE THIS?
WHO WILL BRING THIS UP?
TWO INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE LEAVING
THE SENATE GOING TO WRITE A BILL
WHERE THEY HAD $100 BILLION MORE
DOLLARS AND OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WILL WRITE IT?
THIS IS THOUSANDS OF PAGES.
HOW -- I KNOW WHY THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO DO IT.
BECAUSE IF THEY PUT ALL OF THEIR
DIRECTION, ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY CARE MOST ABOUT AND WE
END UP WHERE WE CAN'T COME TO AN
AGREEMENT AND YOU END UP WITH A
CONTINUING RESOLUTION, ALL THE
VALUES THAT THEY JUST PUT IN
CONTINUE GOING FORWARD.
THAT'S WHY WE SHOULD WAIT AND
NOT LET THE DEMOCRATS ADD ANY
NEW THING --
>> Sean: TO BE CLEAR, THIS HAS
TO BE STOPPED IN THE SENATE.
THIS HAS TO BE --
>> IT'S NOT HAPPENING IN THE
HOUSE.
>> Sean: MITCH McCONNELL LEADING
THE WAY.
WHEN THE NEW CONGRESS IS SWORN
IN, WHEN THE NEW CONGRESS IS
SWORN IN, YOU'LL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE A SAY.
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO CUT THE WASTE,
THE FRAUD AND THE ABUSE, WHICH
WAS PART OF YOUR COMMITMENTS TO
AMERICA.
THAT WOULD BE YOUR FIRST PROMISE
FULFILLED, RIGHT?
>> THINK ABOUT WHAT ELSE WE
COULD PUT IN THIS BILL?
WE COULD PUT SECURING THE
BORDER.
>> Sean: IRS AGENT.
>> EXACTLY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN IN
POWER.
THEY'VE HAD THE HOUSE, THE
SENATE AND THE PRESIDENCY.
THEY DIDN'T DO THIS JOB.
WHY WOULD REPUBLICANS HELP THEM
NOW TO PUT IN THE THINGS THAT
THEY CARE ABOUT?
WHY NOT WAIT 21 DAYS AND LET
WHAT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC JUST
SAID IN THE LAST ELECTION, TO
HAVE A NEW DIRECTION.
TO TAKE AWAY THE 87,000 IRS
AGENTS.
LET'S PARENTS HAVE A SAY IN
EDUCATION.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHY DO IT IN THE MIDDLE OF
CHRISTMAS.
>> Sean: EVERY PERSON WATCHING
NEEDS TO CALL THEIR SENATOR AND
SAY NO TO THE OMNIBUS SPENDING
BILL.
LET THE NEW REPUBLICAN HOUSE
HAVE A SAY IN HOW MUCH MONEY --
HOW MUCH OF YOUR MONEY THAT
THEY'LL SPEND HERE.
THE SENATE, DOING THIS, EVEN
CONSIDERING THIS IS RECKLESS
BEYOND ANY COMPREHENSION I HAVE.
RICHARD SHELBY, GREAT CAREER.
WHAT HE'S DOING IS WRONG, FULL
OF WASTE, FRAUD AND ABUSE.
HE WON'T HAVE TIME TO READ IT
AND NEITHER WILL ANY OTHER
SENATOR.
LET ME MOVE ON.
>> YOU WANT TO HOLD THOSE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE PEOPLE THAT VOTE FOR THIS
ARE LEAVING.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO VOTE FOR HAVE
MUCH MONEY, LET THE CONSTITUENTS
HAVE A SAY WHETHER IT'S RIGHT OR
WRONG.
WAIT 21 DAYS.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE ASKING.
>> Sean: SO "WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTS BIDEN SUPPORTERS WILL BE
OUT THERE AND HAVE A CAMPAIGN OF
INTIMIDATING WITNESSES,
INVESTIGATION, INVESTIGATORS OR
ANYBODY THAT DARES TO CHALLENGE
ALL OF THESE BUSINESS DEALINGS
OF HUNTER BIDEN WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE APPARENTLY OF HIS
FATHER.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHAT WILL
REPUBLICANS DO IN RESPONSE TO
THESE INTIMIDATION TACTICS?
>> WE'RE JUST GOING TO FOLLOW
THE TRUTH AND LET THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEE WHAT'S OUT THERE.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF COMMITTEES
IN CONGRESS.
WE'RE GOING TO DO SOME OF
EVERYTHING.
WE HAVE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND JUDICIARY.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT WORK AT
THE SAME TIME AS WE MAKE
HOURSELVES ENERGY INDEPENDENT,
SECURING OUR BORDER.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE HERE, YOU
HAVE TO BE FEARLESS IN THIS.
WHY ARE THEY INTIMIDATE
SOMETHING THEY'RE TRYING TO DO
THE SAME THING THAT THEY WANTED
TO DO ELON MUSK.
THE MOMENT HE SAID HE WAS GOING
TO BUY A COMPANY, WHY DO THEY
START ATTACKING HIM?
THEY KNEW WHAT HE WOULD FIND.
THEY KNEW WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
IN WHOLE IDEA OF THAT CLIP YOU
PLAYED EARLIER, THAT YOU HAD 51
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE IN THE
INTEL COMMUNITY, THE CLAPPER,
THE BRENNANS, THE FORMER CIA, TO
SIGN A LETTER TO TELL US IT WAS
RUSSIAN COLLUSION AGAIN, THAT IT
WASN'T TRUE WHEN THEY KNEW THAT.
BUT YOU HAD TWITTER, FACEBOOK,
GOOGLE.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC SHOULDN'T BE
INTIMIDATED LIKE THIS.
THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
SHOULDN'T HAVE LIABILITY
PROTECTION.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS DESTROYED THE
INTEL COMMUNITY.
HE LIED TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
FIRST ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
THEN HE LIED ABOUT HIS STAFF
COORDINATING WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HE LIED ABOUT HAVING MORE THAN
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
WHILE HE WAS DOING ALL THIS, TIN
TELL COMMITTEE WASN'T DOING
THEIR WORK.
AFGHANISTAN COLLAPSED.
CHINA WAS SPREADING A VIRUS
AROUND THE WORLD.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITH RUSSIA
AND UKRAINE?
WE'RE TRYING TO TURN THE INTEL
COMMITTEE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE.
ADAM SHIFT WON'T BE ON THERE OR
NEITHER ERIC SWALWELL.
BECAUSE OF THE BRIEFING I GOT
FROM THE FBI THAT THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT HE HAD WITH A
CHINESE SPY, THERE'S A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS THAT HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SERVE ON THERE.
HE WILL NOT GET A SECURITY
CLEARANCE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
>> Sean: THE FBI WAS MEETING
WITH BIG TECH EVERY WEEK BEFORE
THE ELECTION, EVEN ELON MUSK
SAID THE SUPPRESSION OF
CONSERVATIVE DISSENTING VOICES
WAS BY ITS VERY DEFINITION
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
HE POINTED OUT THAT THE MEDIA
WAS COMPLICIT.
HE POINTED OUT TWITTER WAS A
PROPAGANDA ARM OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
DO WE NEED REGULATION FOR BIG
TECH?
>> YES.
>> Sean: WILL THERE BE AN
INVESTIGATION TO WHY THE FBI WAS
MANIPULATING BIG TECH AND THE
LEAD UP TO THIS ELECTION?
WHY THEY HELPED IN THE
SUPPRESSION OF THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY?
>> WE, WE'LL HAVE THAT.
SEAN, WHAT WE REALLY HAVE TO
HAVE HAPPEN, WE CAN'T DELAY
THAT.
WE CAN'T HAVE SOMETHING GO WRONG
ON JANUARY 3.
WE HAVE TO HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING.
REPEAL THE IRS AGENTS AND HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GIVE THE AMERICAN